nun kommt also der alte bundessprecher
2017 hat jack leuten 72 prozent bekommen
nun muss er sich gegen zwei andere
bewerber durchsetzen so als wenn die
fragen erst einmal die fragen genau in
sicht fragmentierte ein polizeiliches
führungszeugnis eintragungen natürlich
nicht und gab es vor der afg andere
parteimitgliedschaft
ich habe es schon oft sagen müssen ich
sage es nochmal nein und es wird auch
danach keine geben dann laufen jetzt
fünf minuten zeit für die vorstellung
bitteschön liebe parteifreunde unsere
heimat deutschland steht nach mehr als
14 jahren desaströser merkel regierung
an einer historischen wegscheide
niemand kann übersehen dass die
ehemaligen volksparteien union und spd
zur politischen führung unseres landes
schlicht nicht mehr imstande sind
die spd kämpft gegen die einstelligkeit
ein kampf den sie im osten bereits
verloren hat es ist niedergang pur und
kein neues führungsduo dass wir heute
abend präsentiert bekommen wird das meer
aufhalten und die cdu zitat die cdu ist
inhaltlich insolvent so resümiert ist
der fraktionsvorsitzende im stuttgarter
landtag volker reinhardt noch selten hat
ein führender cdu funktionären so
schonungslos das eigene debatte gesehen
und nun liebe freunde
wer übernimmt in dieser so
entscheidenden zeit die verantwortung
und her kann das eine alternative für
deutschland tut mehr noten geben und
wenn wir nicht bereit stehen
dann werden wir hier bald vom pseudo
grünen öko sozialisten regiert da genau
da steht unser land heute und dann gehen
alle unsere werte verloren
die einzigen die das noch aufhalten
können in diesem land das entleeren
dass es eine notlage und diese notlage
zwingt uns dazu verdammt schnell zu
lernen und ich sage es klipp und klar
wir müssen nun regierungs willig und
fähig werden das ist uns aufgetragen
das ist die aufgabe für die nächsten
zwei jahren
wir können und dürfen uns nicht länger
mit internem zwist und persönliche
animositäten aufhalten die zum teil
chaotische findungsphase unserer partei
ist gottseidank vorüber chaos gibt es
heute eher bei cdu und spd während wir
als afd das spüren auch unsere gegner
immer besser und stärker werden die
zurückliegende amtszeit von hannover bis
heute hat den weg zur notwendigen
professionalisierung und ein gutes stück
vorangetrieben und die feste verankerung
in allen parlamenten unseres landes
gebracht das ist lassen wir uns das
bitte von niemandem kleinen das ist ein
riesenerfolg und ich wenn ich bin enorm
stolz darauf was wir gemeinsam bisher
erreicht haben und dann jeder aktive in
jeder funktion für die partei hat daran
seinen anteil und auch stolz darauf sein
das schafft keiner alleine liebe freunde
das schafft man wirklich nur gemeinsam
doch wir dürfen gerade jetzt nicht
stehen bleiben denn jetzt jetzt kommt
erst die eigentliche bergetappe die
erneute amtszeit die ich heute anstrebe
soll die zwingend notwendige
professionalisierung bis zur wirklichen
regierungsfähigkeit vorantreiben
die jahre 2020 und 20 21 werden ganz
entscheidend für unsere partei die für
unser land im ganzen
wenn wir das blatt in dieser zeit nicht
wenden wird es zu spät sein wir müssen
bereit sein
deutschland braucht uns liebe freunde
weil wir wollen dass unsere kinder und
enkel hier genauso frei und ohne noten
werden leben können wie wir das konnte
und dazu braucht unsere partei eine
führung die diese aufgabe intellektuell
und mental gewachsen ist eine
routinierte und selbstbewusster führung
die angesichts noch so massiver
widerstände nicht in die knie geht
es braucht dazu eine ruhige hand starke
nerven und eine ausgewogene mischung aus
gelassenheit und zugleich
entschlossenheit
liebe freunde ich bin bescheiden ich bin
überzeugt ich bringe alters mit ich
bringe das mit
aus der kraft wie meine liebe und große
und wundervolle familie mehr gibt und
auch aus der die mir mein glaube schenkt
ich empfinde durchaus demut vor der
größe der aufgabe aber ich habe auch
einen unerschütterlichen kompass nämlich
folge
ihr wisst und sollte auch wissen für was
ich stehe und antrete mein kurs ist
konservativ freiheitlich und patriotisch
konservativen nicht reaktionär
freiheitlich nicht beliebiges liberal
allah patriotisch nicht nationalistisch
die links roten verseuchten
achtundsechziger ich habe das ja schon
meinen stunden hat geprägt mögen das
noch so sehr verachtet und bekämpfen und
das tun sie aber das ist mein credo und
wird es immer bleiben ebenso gewiss ist
dass ich mein gesicht nicht für eine
partei hergeben werde die schleichen in
die tolerierung extremistische
positionen abrutschte ich sage das ganz
klar und deutlich
sie sagen dass ganz klar und deutlich
für eine rechtsaußen partei stünde ich
dich zur verfügung für eine wahrhaft
konservative freiheitliche und
patriotische partei aber aus vollster
überzeugung und mit ganzem herzen ganz
konkret und an einem beispiel
ich halte die unvereinbarkeit ist
absolut und lehrlingen werde deren
abschaffung keinesfalls zu schinden
[Applaus]
nur mit bürgerlicher vernunft mit klaren
konzerten pro episode zeit können und
werden in deutschland den so notwendigen
guten dienst erweisen
dafür stehe ich heute wie immer ihr euch
entscheidet ich werde dieses votum mit
einem ecktisch in demut annehmen
dankeschön
vielen dank
erneuten der bisherige bundessprecher
der afg hat sich hier noch einmal
deutlich gegen den rechtsextremen rand
gewandt gesagt dafür gibt es keinen
platz das hat er schon in der
vergangenheit getan und deswegen gibt es
auch schätzungen dass der flügel ihn nun
bei der wahl nicht unterstützen könnte
die drei frage schon aus die erste frage
kommen von andrea weinhart
die zweite frage von michael voigt und
eine dritte frage von taras andreas
winhart am saalmikrofon roth bitteschön
sehr geehrte professor wollten sie haben
am 15 10 2018 sich über mich in der
fernseh sendung anne will geäußert wir
hatten uns zuvor nie persönlich
getroffen nie telefoniert ich hätte mir
eigentlich damals gewünscht dass du
jetzt müssen sich meine nummer besorgen
einmal mehr nach vorn lagen
meine frage wer bleibt dass ihr stil
oder wollen sie jetzt auch mit
hintergrund der ganzen ordnungsmaßnahmen
die wir in der partei haben und sie
darin kommunikativen spiel an den tag
legen vielen dank und die antriebe
erinnert das kann meinen stil nicht
bleiben weil es mein stil ist in dieser
fernsehsendung wurde ich mit der frage
konfrontiert und haben wir mit dieser
frage in der tat ich erinnere mich nicht
gerecht und insofern konnte ich dann
keine rücksprache mit ihnen nehmen wann
immer ich nicht einverstanden bin mit
äußerung das werde viele bestätigen auch
viele anwesenden im saal pflege ich
immer eigentlich erstmal das direkte
gespräch ich rufe an oder suchen die
persönliche begegnung zu klären was
wurde gesagt es tut mir leid dass das in
ihrem fall nicht möglich war denn das
ist eigentlich richtige vorgehensweise
da gebe ich ihnen recht
dankeschön bekommt die zweite frage von
michael voigt ebenfalls am roten saal
mikrofon
ja lieber professor wollten eigentlich
bin ich ja ihretwegen in die partei
eingetreten also ihre knallharten
kompromisslose völlig weiß jeder hier in
braunschweig zu unserer landtagswahl 20
17 hat mich überzeugt dass ich bei
diesen ritt dann von recht und ordnung
und anstand mitmachen muss jetzt in
letzter zeit mit ein bisschen
verunsichert als sie ihr sommerinterview
fand ich ein bisschen defensiv deswegen
meine frage was kriegen wir denn jetzt
immer sie wählen bekommen bei unseren
rat cor frontkämpfer professor der alle
rhetorischen der ersten runde platte
haut oder kriegen wir weichen cdu 20 und
relativierung und dergleichen filter
vielen dank und verantworten
also wissen sie ich komme ein bisschen
aus dem sportlich und sie werden sie
werden meister nur dann werden wenn sie
sowohl die defensive als auch die
offensive beherrschen und das heißt
manchmal muss man wirklich stören und
manchmal muss man voran und muss die
dinge ins torhaus und manchmal muss man
in der defensive auch sehen dass man
hinten zu machen damit man nicht selber
einkassiert ich hab das sommerinterview
mit theo koll ganz anders erlebt vor
allen dingen lesen sie vielleicht mal in
die kommentare rein da sind die
kommentare ganz ganz überwiegend positiv
es gab einen punkt der mich sehr
geärgert hat da haben einige male lösen
streich gespielt indem sie etwas raus
geschnitten haben auf einen nichtmals
auf ein halbsatz der dann suggerierte
ich hätte dort insinuiert der flügel
gehören nicht zur partei das hatte ich
so überhaupt nicht gesagt sondern ich
hatte etwas ganz anderes gesagt ich
hatte gesagt das war eine juristische
aussage ich hatte klar gesagt
selbstverständlich gehören die vielen
menschen des flügels wie alle anderen zu
unserer partei die sich an recht und
gesetz halten die zur fdp steht die
hälfte unserer programmatik fehlen die
wenigen nicht bei denen das nicht der
fall ist werde das genau das dankeschön
und die dritte frage kommen von charisma
cum laude saal mikrofon
beim kreisverband ortenau folgendes ich
habe gerade diese woche eine abmahnung
vom landesverband wegen eines facebook-
fonds bekommen dass werber
parteischädigend hat nicht mal facebook
zu beanstanden und jetzt habe ich eine
frage an sie an ihr verständnis von
parteischädigend sie haben nach der wahl
für die delegierten in der ortenau im
deutschlandfunk
haben sie gesagt unser kreisverband sei
problematisch die ist das
demokratieverständnis und wo bleibt da
ihre gelassenheit die zuvor angekündigt
haben
dankeschön zur antwort so also zur
ersten teil ihrer frage kann in die
gesamt weil ich bin ich landesvorstand
in baden württemberg ich weiß also gar
nicht um welchen vorgang ist geht dafür
bitte ich um nachsicht
was machst du das zweite anbelangt ja im
kreisverband ortenau gibt es einige
probleme in größerem maße als in anderen
kreisverbänden und das hängt zum teil
mit handelnden akteuren zusammen einer
hat sich heute hier schon besonders oft
zu wort gemeldet und ich meine
kann ich meine auch ich meine auch einen
kreisverband der gruppenrunde 250
mitglieder hat nicht damit ihre parabel
zu beschädigen wenn ich darauf hinweise
dass es da auch problematische
mitglieder gibt das darf man sagen und
ich stehe dazu
gott sei dank ist aber die mehrheit
unproblematisch und auch dazu stehe ich
vielen dank das waren drei fragen und
beantworten und dann sind sie mit danke
lassen